the scp foundation handles all kinds of
anomalies and abnormalities from horrors
beyond thought to the most simple
cryptids it goes without saying that
ghosts are included after all every
culture has stories about ghosts spirits
and hauntings but your average
poltergeists are nothing special to the
hardened agents and researchers of the
foundation they've seen so many that
there have been studies written on their
behavior what could possibly still be
scary about them in 1999 the foundation
found out that the only thing more
terrifying than a ghost is the absence
of one but let's go back in time a
little way back in 1961 the foundation
were informed of a little town in the
mississippi backwoods called paulinsby
allegedly a hot spot for all sorts of
anomalies the town was mostly owned by
the burnley family a long lineage of
magicians occultists and alchemists in
the deep south their power so notable
even the foundation of yesteryear
decided that they were better left alone
after conducting some cursory
reconnaissance on the famous patriarch
of the family a herosographer named lyle
alan burnley and the ancestral estate of
elelene the foundation decided to leave
paulinsby for another day
that day came in 1978.
lyle alan burnley died and the estate
passed into the hands of the municipal
government that's where the foundation
stepped in they had heard lots of
stories from frightened tourists of
elelene being haunted of the land being
cursed they took ownership and to their
shock found that these weren't just the
ravings of spook travelers elene really
was haunted but these ghosts weren't
hateful or malicious they were barely
even significant enough to be worth
containment so the foundation decided
not to waste their resources on
containing an entire estate
they cut a deal with the surviving
burnleys so long as they made sure the
revenants of burnley manor stayed in
line the foundation wouldn't bother them
this worked great all the way until the
fateful year of 1999.
none of the burnleys remained in the
dilapidated mansion anymore and the
foundation began receiving reports of a
new anomaly classified as scp-6274
the ghosts of the burnley estate were
lashing out and then
disappearing defying the foundation's
understanding of how ghosts work an
excerpt written by lyle allen burnley
regarding the haunting says no two
haltons are quite alive though they
share some common properties let us
dispel the notion that all our
translucent people wandering around
after dark to scare children a revenant
can take any number of forms from a
phenomenon to a place
while i cannot speak for all of them
those that i encountered in my home life
at the estate were universally positive
and helpful to a fault the most
universal property being that they do
not leave the occultists of yore thought
that the spirits could be banished or
exercised they were incorrect in the
decades since society learned of their
existence methods have been proposed and
tested to permanently remove them all
are prohibitively expensive and none
have ever worked at best their actions
can be temporarily dampened but they
will never go away a crew from mtf mew13
were set into ellen to investigate the
situation they entered to find the
entire sprawling mansion without power
and in disrepair the paint peeling and
the roofs collapsing they advanced
through the building putting down
surveillance cameras and microphones
trying to find the status of the ghosts
they find a door to the wine cellar that
against all force just won't open behind
it the sounds of breathing with no
choice they draw a rune on the door and
leave finding a dining hall filled with
rotten food on their way back the ruin
had been erased they reassure themselves
that there was nothing to be afraid of
and continue into the main hall that's
when it hits them the ghosts of elene
are awake they see horrifying
apparitions on their way through to the
other wing of the mansion where many of
the doors are barred from the inside the
one that isn't contains a fancy covered
bed and dozens of candles covering every
surface somehow they don't realize one
of them has gone missing then something
happens something
bad the entire section of the
documentation is expunged when it clears
up two agents are reported waking up in
the garden holding a book and looking at
a tree growing around a human body they
rush back into the house and into the
kitchen but the house has changed from
the inside they find the body of the
absent agent and a single finger coming
from the bottom of the sealed door the
documentation expunges itself just as
the surviving agent arms herself when it
ends all there is left to do is for the
agent's body to be recovered hours later
from the porch along with the book the
sacrifice of the agents lets the
foundation discover a few things the
dining room the bedroom and the tree are
the sights of ellen's last ghosts the
feast the brood and the totem the book
seems to be a diary written by mr
burnley recording all the ghosts of the
manor and their history and dedicated to
his four children the foundation
prepares one of their mediums they must
commune with the ghosts of eloleen first
comes the feast the fish is an entity
inhabiting the silverton dining room
among the most docile of those that
inhabit our home as a boy it was a
favorite plaything as a young man an
endless source of amazement for the
ladies of the town when they came up to
the manor as an older man a close
confidant for when one wishes to shut
out the troubles of the world with food
and drink without conversation it is an
arrangement of delicacies and perfectly
cooked meats with aged wines in all
manner of side dishes roasted ham seared
steaks cooked goose and veal the exact
contents change regularly i remember
arthur and i breakfast making a game of
guessing what would be on the table by
nightfall he adored the room nearly as
much as i like many other revenants in
elelene it seeks only to live in happy
coexistence with the current generation
of burnley's inhabiting the home for the
feast this means providing delicious
food and the enjoyment that comes from a
full belly after much time in the
family's archives in the library i
ventured forth a guess that the feast
was once abraham burnley a noted
gastronome and gourmet dead in 1845 i've
had little luck in communion with him in
the usual method it seems he's happy to
limit his interaction with the world to
one's taste buds the feast is a
food-based revenant despite mr burnley's
claims all it produces now is rotten
maggot-ridden food filled with razor
blades shrapnel and bugs the
foundation's medium known only as zee
sits down and begins the ritual in the
dining room her cries are met with small
shifts a plate moving meat falling apart
a breeze suddenly she announces to her
guards that something is wrong that
there is no ghost an impossibly old
voice speaks through her and to her it
tells her
there is no spirit to be found here only
absences
only
nothing there is nothing to be afraid of
in the dark then in a whisper that the
cellar can only be opened by the masters
of the house then the ritual breaks and
all parties look to the table where
there are hundreds of glasses of a dark
wine since then the feast hasn't shown
any activity a misconception that ghosts
spirits revenants whatever you choose to
call them are utterly and totally
divorced from the world which we inhabit
that their interaction is limited to
that of a common poltergeist
throwing vases and banging together pots
and pans like a choleric child not so
revenants are not altogether unlike
living humans they feel emotion they are
driven by something though they do not
know what one could say this goes for
most all creatures they rage when they
are upset when they are angry bitter
frightened of something a wise man i met
in jordan some years ago told me that
every revenant is anchored by something
in the living world be it a person an
object a location something that they
left behind when this anchor is removed
the revenant ceases to exist what
remains is something else
then comes the brood as a child i was
warned against going into the bedroom in
the western wing we all knew the one it
was never locked bunnies do not believe
in stifling exploration but i was told
quite sternly by my father that i would
be solely and entirely responsible for
what i found inside decades later i told
matilda the same thing when she asked
what was inside naturally it stopped
neither of us none of the revenants in
burnley manor are dangerous but a fair
few simply wish to be left alone the
brood is one of these i have no idea how
old it is i've asked everyone and
searched to the bottom of the archives
but no one seems to know where it came
from presumably it does not predate the
creation of the western wing itself in
1798 but who can say for certain the
brood takes the form of a woman in the
throes of childbirth in her bed chambers
she screams cries and generally spans
visitors reasonably enough the curtains
open for only a few seconds but in those
seconds any questions you ask the poor
thing are answered with all the truth of
the universe my father was right
knowledge is not a burden a child should
bear not a day goes by where i do not
remember matilda weeping as she hugged
me all the brood does now is sit inside
the impenetrable bed constantly softly
weeping and occasionally throwing an
object from inside the curtains though
never daring to open them z navigates
through the candles and kneels by the
foot of the bed requesting an audience
only to be met with a flung baby rattle
and a woman's soft voice asking who's
there demanding where her family has
gone and begging for help because
nothing's coming out before z can even
respond the woman inside the bed screams
for her to get the gun then the room
goes completely dark the same ancient
voice speaks from behind the curtains it
informs her that she wastes her time
with ghosts of ghosts while burnley
manor is eaten around her what has
killed the ghosts of eline impossible as
it may be and what does a ghost leave
behind when killed once again just as z
gets her wits the spell is broken and
the curtains of the bed open revealing a
burned corpse huddled under the sheets
the brood two has fallen silent the burn
negotia like no other haunted manners
are a dime a dozen revenants angry that
they have been forgotten by the world
acting out in crowd of unknown fools
furthering their suffering a tragic
story by any angle but here our ghosts
are not unknowns forgotten by the world
they are remembered burnley's do not shy
away from our ghosts we approach them
with open arms they may not be of this
mortal coil but they are still family
and family is the most important thing
family is what we leave behind in this
world our legacy and our mind we also
leave behind our spirits our revenants
this book is a collection of the ghosts
of burnley manor and the place they hold
in our family the family is the anchor
for all of them i do not like to imagine
a world in which that anchor no longer
exists and so i shall not but when i
walk the grounds at night my children
have all begun i realize i may very well
be the last burnley without me what will
happen to this place the memories i have
forged here with my children my place is
to remember what my ancestors have left
behind what will i leave behind and
finally the totem the totem is a strange
thing i remember long afternoon spent
running through the gardens with my
brothers and sisters the groundskeeper
hated us how we would ruin his perfectly
tended shrubs and we'd be called in for
dinner by the maid and wolfed down the
feast before spending the evening
lounging beneath the totem my
grandfather sat me on his lap and told
me its story one day his own grand uncle
had done a service for the indians that
still dominated our land back then their
specifics of the service are unclear to
me but it was great enough that when he
died they paid their debt and he came
back as a chaplain in the grounds of the
garden that he loved so much the fruit
he produced were one of a kind a large
round thing the size of your face with a
thick purple skin and a juicy red inside
he was our oldest family member we
adored his stories regaling us with
cowboy tales and he was a tree in spirit
happy to watch the world grow around him
the third ghost of ellen sits on the far
edge of the gardens closed off in its
own little pen
the trunk of the tree intertwined with
that of a man his arm reaching out like
a branch before being swallowed up by
the wood growing around him again the
roots and vines have been seen
strangling and choking unwary animals
and personnel dragging them into the
corrosive soil for digestion as such
these communications were performed from
a small drone to everyone's surprise the
totem speaks affirming he was once a
burnley but is now only a hole a gap in
the shape of a burnley not unlike the
rest of the house once it was filled
with the ghosts and revenants of old
members of the burnley clan but
something happened the totem speaks but
its voice ages into oblivion something
cosmic turned its eyes on a family in
mississippi leaving behind nothingness
in its wake i was looking through my
archives just the other day when i came
across an old journal of mine from an
expedition into the iona they have a
rich and ancient culture and as with all
cultures the aspect of mysticism and
spirituality was strong i shared my
knowledge of certain histories and
hearsays and was provided with their own
stories in turn one story was of a man
whose father had been killed in battle
he was told by a shaman that his
father's spirit his revenant was
watching over him and would continue to
do so for his son and his son's son and
so on he was comforted by this knowledge
many years later the man was subject to
a curse from a rival house something to
plague misfortunes upon his family in
those weeks he felt a presence by his
side one he did not even realize was
there change morph something to nothing
like a black hole on his shoulder
constantly pulling the unignorable
presence of nothingness the shaman told
him plainly his father's spirit was no
longer the thing walking behind his side
it troubles me i've seen what my
forefathers have left behind i leave
behind four wonderful children and two
wives i leave behind a body of work as
impressive as any scholar of the
paranormal but my children have no
interest in the occult the family
secrets will die with me whatever i
leave behind will be a habanja of things
to come just as the foundation prepared
to give up the investigation with all
three revenants lying indefinitely
dormant a stroke of luck changed
everything the foundation was approached
by a civilian laura norman once known as
laura burnley disowned by her father in
the very same will that left the house
to the city agreeing to speak with a
researcher she affirmed that she had
tried to avoid her family's legacy and
had not seen the house in years the
house being haunted was just a simple
fact of life not something for the
burnley kids to worry about but instead
housemates and childhood confidants then
she is told that against all logic the
ghosts of burnley manor have been
corrupted and killed and that everything
her father had written and disowned her
to free her from points to whatever
killed them being in the wine cellar
underneath the house laura is in
disbelief not least because the house
does not have a wine cellar she agrees
to open the door that does not exist but
before she does the foundation discovers
three corpses buried in the grounds away
from the house those of henry arthur and
matilda burnley laura's sibling dead for
only a few months as laura prepares to
descend the finger beneath the door
pulls itself back in laura steps into
the dark stairwell surging pointlessly
for a light against the wall as she goes
down the stairs descending into the inky
blackness laura tells the handler that
there was a seller under the house once
as a child her father took her down into
a cavernous empty space and told her he
would build a wine cellar there one day
then she arrives at the bottom
discovering
nothing not just an empty space but
truly nothing the seller is an endless
abyss as she stares out into the void
the realization hits her there is no
wine cellar there are no ghosts merely
the spaces and outlines where they
should be something has consumed the
burnley manor and the last thing the
researchers hear before her microphone
cuts out is an ancient voice behind her
assuring her there is nothing to be
afraid of and her response
dad now go check out
scp-2696 haunted victorian mansion at
scp-4153 haunted house horror it came
from site 9 for more anomalously
chilling haunted house locations